ce dernier donc bonjour merci d'être
avec nous une nouvelle journée de
manifestations interprofessionnelles qui
sera dans la rue aujourd'hui ici bah
écoute et qui se doit dans la rue je
pense que tous les salariés en tout cas
nous espérons que les salariés que ce
soit public ou privé de tous secteurs
confondus seront dans la rue aujourd'hui
parce que nous avons des revendications
à poser où nous nous en avons plusieurs
je peux en citer quelques-unes la
première sur le recrutement en tout cas
pour la sncf recrutement régularisation
de tous les cdd et intérim intérim
ailleurs augmentation des salaires plan
de relance un véritable prendre plan de
relance pour le fret où les trains de
nuit mais aussi maintien et
développement de tout et unifiée
raudière qui ont été massacrées donc
services publics massacré ces dernières
années et en suit extension du statut à
l'ensemble des travailleurs du rail
ça ce sont des revendications parmi
d'autres que la cgt cheminots à porter
et qui savent à qui va se greffer dans
ce mouvement dans cette journée de
mobilisation qui est une journée
interprofessionnelle
il n'y a pas uniquement les chevilles
car la manifestation se déroulera avec
sous ce slogan a mobilisé pour un autre
avenir quelles sont vos principales
revendications c'est clair la
revalorisation des salaires c'est ça le
réel combat
je crois que c'est un combat qui est
universel en fait actuellement qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a eu
affaire à un minéral comique 19 qui nous
ont accusés tomber tu repars revenir sur
les origines et les le la véritable
dangerosité de ces virus moi j'ai un
avis assez tranchée mais en tout cas
toujours est il que pendant qu'au xixe 9
ce qui s'est passé c'est que les forces
du capital
le patronat et le capital de grands
représentants du capitole en général on
utilise et profiter de cette situation
fragile pour durcir leur dictature la
dictature du capital et on voit bien que
tous les séries galère en france tout
simplement où qu'ils soient publics ou
privés tous les salariés galère donc à
un moment comme vous n'avez pas de
salaire à salaire de décembre pour
pouvoir vivre pour pouvoir payer votre
loyer pour pouvoir faire des courses etc
etc
la maman à un moment il faut il faut se
défendre et la cgt a posé effectivement
dans une une des seront de série roddick
à sion s'est effectivement augmentation
des salaires et revalorisation de nos
primes mais c'est aussi le salaire de
tous les travailleurs parce qu'à partir
du bon on dole où le sait marier
c'est à dire une personne vend sa force
de travail parce qu'on parle bien de ça
alors qu'une personne vend ça le
prolétariat c'est quoi le mandat qu'on
vient sur certaines définitions qui ont
été particulièrement massacrées pendant
que les 19 qu'est ce qu'un point les
terres à prôner terre c'est une personne
qui n'a uniquement qui a sa force de
travail à vendre et qui va vendre
effectivement au capital pour vivre et
faire vivre sa famille c'est simple
prenez terre ans qu'est ce qu'on peut
constater c'est que en france la plupart
de ceux qui travaillent en france qui
font tourner ce pays ce sont des
prolétaires le premier périard en france
ce n'est pas une minorité domine et
c'est une majorité dominé donc en parle
bien de salaire qui suffit pas pour
payer
ne suffit pas pour vivre et encore nous
savons des cheminots sens europe s'en
sort pas mal mais moi j'ai des amis je
vais vous dire qu'ils galèrent et lionel
ils sont même plus dans toi donc à
vraiment alors que vous touchez league
bâle concrètement si vous touchez iban
et vous pouvez pas payer votre loyer
alors que dans le même temps vous avez
des jeff bezos s'est par exemple entre
autres c'est un des grands représentants
du capital qui jackpot en une journée en
poche plusieurs milliards de dollars
pardon il ya un truc qui va pas alors
une manifestation qui se passe
voilà sous le signe du corona virus on
sait qu'il ya des mesures sanitaires qui
sont prises actuellement alors faut-il
justement s'attendre à une mobilisation
davantage militante que sur le terrain
tout à fait en fait avait alors je pense
que 7e enfin il ya deux axes deux axes
qu'il faut vraiment le premier
le premier axe et l'on va dire le cas
général une grève quel que soit ils
menaient une grève et une manifestation
grèves et manifestations quel que soit
le secteur de production dans lesquelles
elles se elle se gênèrent a toujours une
utilité pourquoi parce qu'une grève elle
va pouvoir poser va permettre aux
salariés de poser des revendications
mais aussi acquérir de nouvelles
conquêtes sociales
en tout cas tendres avaient acquérir de
nouvelles conquêtes sociales et ensuite
on a à la grève et les manifestations de
manière concrète celle ci le 17
bon ben il y aura effectivement deux
obstacles le premier obstacle ce sont
les bas le fait que en tout cas chez les
cheminots il ya eu une grève une grande
grève dernièrement contre la retraite à
points ou contrôler il y en avait
plusieurs églises et les cheminots ont
été fragilisés financièrement
donc ça c'est la preuve le premier
obstacle le désert où cet obstacle
effectivement s'il ya des règles
sanitaires qui pareil j'ai un avis assez
franche et je crois que ces règles
sanitaires est un paravent que le
capital va utiliser que les forces du
capital quand utilisait pour renforcer
leur dictature leur dictature du capital
et on a bien compris que parler
franchement alors que pendant qu'on nous
dit que les 19 et la règle sanitaire
nous empêche de manifester
vous pouvez aller un spectacle au coût
du fou où vous avez plusieurs événements
alors pour un chat un chat
moi j'aime pas me cacher derrière des
jolis mots pompeux qui font boum on a
des bourgeois qui se réunissent et qui
font ce qu'ils veulent
vous avez plusieurs événements en fait
non rexel et ermont d'accord alors je
dis pas qu'il faut pas faire attention
et je dis pas que le coc u19 n'existe
pas attention je ne suis pas con
puntistes je suis syndicaliste
donc on est donc scientifique ce que je
dis c'est que à un moment il faut qu'on
arrête de nous prendre pour des cons et
il ya des salaires qui vont qui ne vont
pas il
mission de travail et de vie qui ne vont
pas qu'ils vont s'aggraver et elles vont
s'aggraver
parce que la france en tant que pays
impérialistes est conditionnée par un
capital financier excécrable dominant
puissant qui s'est accaparé la planète
qui va renforcer sa dictature
concrètement on a des jeunes me daligou
d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne je
rappelle que vous êtes élu cgt
schmidt